[Musique]
l'île de france est la première région
en europe sur l'aéronautique et le
spatial et on compte bien le rester
toutes les quatre secondes ni un avion
qui décolle dans le monde avec un moteur
qui fabriquait en ile de france
donc nous on veut non seulement soutenir
cette filière mais également l'aider à
se moderniser à devenir plus vertueuses
et donc le fab lab dédié à l'avion
électrique sur le site de l'aéroport
toussus le noble et un très bel exemple
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on n'a
pas hésité une seule seconde avec
valérie pécresse à l'accompagner
financièrement il ya un enjeu évidemment
environnementale d'innovation pour la
filière aéronautique puisque ça va
permettre de financer deux avions
électriques qui ont été livrés en juin
en octobre 2020 donc ça permet de
limiter la pollution de l'air la
pollution sonore qui aussi un grand
sujet dans notre dans notre région et
aussi d'avoir un temps d'avancé
d'innover de réfléchir à l'avion du
futur
et donc c'est important je pense
d'accompagner ces filières dans leur
transition pour qu'elle perdure et
quelque 7 des étendards qu'elle
continuait des étendards de de notre
pays à l'international
c'est important projet qui est porté par
la fédération française d'aéronautique
et il va à la fois ce projet offrir ce
fab lab un panel de services qui
comprend la mise à disposition d'avions
électrique pour contribuer au
développement de la filière lait de
france et ça permettra de mutualiser
l'usagé d'équipements innovants
électrique de faire collaborer des
acteurs de différents horizons
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
voulu absolument accompagner ce projet
voilà on ne pense pas que qu'il faille
interdire encore une fois mais et des
dents grâce à l'innovation à rendre
toutes ces filières plus vertueuse